forse per tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
nessuno io sono felice io ci siamo dati
quel gioco bello che stavano un sacco
che però ne fornai dai ragazzi non ci
prova a giocare con la play perché da un
botto di tempo che non gioco a premi di
un video noi la trovo fatto solo un
video con la play tempo fa quindi allora
ragazzi non gliela danno un gioco mai
con la play quindi non so effettivamente
se è più facile più di efficienza cosa
non l'ho mai capita prove di hit parade
la partenza è buona perché praticamente
hit parade non è male non gioco non
salda un sacco con la plaine ho iniziato
a giocare sono poi due pc per allenarmi
sui chip le realta credo sia la stessa
cosa solo che non solo ha risposta ai
comandi la playstation come 23 21 mag
la partenza è buona siamo partiti già
che partiamo in prima fila e un culo o
pazzesco perché non vi capita
praticamente mai
teoricamente ci dovrebbe portare mamma
mia sono primissimo incredibile arrivare
primi visto livello subito non ha senso
tanto la gente di schiaccia contro le le
le cose spiega sto parlando mi posso
concentrare parlavo sui giovani milano
porco demonio
il primo livello non lo faccio city
oddio mamma mia a crearsi giocata al
leader sto dicendo che non ha senso
all'inizio essere primi all'inizio
perché tanto arrivati alle pale dovete
essere in un tot di persone da spingere
da solo le spinge i fatti mi hanno
recuperato di porca vacca questo io l'ho
sempre visto molto standard come livello
ragazzo va beh secondo me i ragazzi non
donano non è un codice non è difficile
the sun è stata ok perfetto quindi
essere mai stato eliminato che il crash
tanto basta a capire quale che scende
per primo sarà in mezzo ragazzi mezzo di
mezzi e mezzo tutti i quartieri che sono
perfetto tempismo ragazzi fire in the
best thing e il my life
di sicuro not i capelli roll out su
playstation phone let's go e vediamo che
succede
32 ruolo led gol subito al lato ragazzi
slalom tra il primo e il secondo cerchio
tanto sempre positivo chi sta in mezzo
perde sempre e firmò mensile the
cambiare adesso forse ai ragazzi
ripartiamo gran torino di poca rai sono
rifatto tutto sono arrivati al terzo
mini gioco perché non volevo farli
vedere i primi due mini giochi perché
demoni con la tastiera la posso spaccare
non mi serve adesso digiuno raga che era
la prima volta nella mia vita e non so
mai caduti l'uno all'altro si è fatta
cadere in un roll out jump club
l'ultimo calcio giocato penso sia stato
all'inizio c'era il primo secondo
episodio andava alle 10 non ha dolore
ok ormai sono abituato a jean showdown
15 all'ansia preside ma non è l'ultimo
livello di rosa la facciata tranquillo
non facciamo le cagate come il rollout
perché lì è stato veramente imbarazzante
scusatemi ragazzi non sono anche come
aiuto di stato dio
oddio rischiato come non so cosa io sono
cascato il rollout potete cadere voi
jobs come si chiama jump club club
non ci siamo veramente mai a jam club
rarissimo l'hanno tolta dalla rotation
secondo me perché non esce mai sono
sempre le stesse
ultimamente dai ma che palle vabbè se ho
ragazzi veramente c'è una croce per
forma basta polmoni cioè io sto fermo
boso joystick o il monte in one non è
che non serve non è che non vinco e che
non è meritocratica alto dall'inizio se
serve perfetta che arrivavo tè caldo
all'inizio incredibile non è che non
vinco e che non è meritocratica se
vincono me lo merito se perdono me lo
merito
dio lo schivata forse più o meno chi
vince a paul martens non se lo merita
ragazze perché non dava fanku perché
baku lo ripete cosa ti cade addosso
troppe cose dipende cosa dichiara
addosso ma veramente troppo a quello che
ormai va veramente troppo acuta ma extra
con una mappa meritocratico che stiamo
passato aveva tanto non entrato la
risposta alla domanda ma neanche io lo
sai palais ragazzi vi parte direttamente
nella dopo il secondo mini gioco perché
se no stiamo 42 anni ho fatto
we are la wilde lo so ma è così si
pronuncia con le cacchio caso di eliche
e ho fatto rollout saltano vinto le dai
basta andiamo avanti
io ho tagliato le prime due parti che 61
miguel questo video già dura troppo vivi
almeno conteniamo ragazzi lei si è la
mia preferita come dico sempre metà
squadra da parte del tas una dall'altra
l'ex bomber
no non è vero siete dei schifosi line i
non è vero non è vero avevo preso anche
il primo fate vomitare ma non è vero
l'ho preso io
madonna il lag io veramente non questo
ok ma quello di prima ma l'ho preso io
ma perché non mi dava da vivere che
questa perdiamo perché non mi dai cerchi
quando salto con qualcuno l'ho da sempre
all'altro che ci sono già una
maledizione ma dimmelo aia per cascato
in cerchio in testa le toghe va per
quanto cerchi e ho preso quello dove
sarà già buttata perfetto tempismo dai
non ci arriverò mai qua eh vabbè tanto
non ci si può arrivare lo sapevo
poi vai dove la mamma mia che sudata
bruttissima partita di ucsi dei brutti
orribile non mi è piaciuto niente di
questa partita gene faccio molto meglio
però vabbè igiene veramente sono molto
più bravi nei silenzi solo che io in
questo calore mi tuffo prima in moda ma
altro
veramente io non so cosa dire 17 17 con
ci fa fare
tic toc scommetti tutto quello che vuoi
a by the fight ice and fire il biscione
saranno ma in italiano sto gioco anche
perché non è che ci voglia tanto a
tradurre con due righe
chi se ne frega non è che ci abbia
bisogno però avrebbe anche più pubblico
paola prova a buttarmi a caso tante la
prima figura
io veramente non ho mai speranza
l'inizio ragazzi tattica solita di tito
rimaniamo indietro e facciamo
sacrificare gli altri serve solo questo
la pina basta quindi siano che stanno
troppo lunga ma che cazzo di nome non mi
spinge te ga fastidio basta che si sa
che dicano gli altri ragazzi perché
tanto uno io so spiega quindi in un
hotel in ebook succedere questo stava
facendo nuovo incredibile brava la
polizia quando a purissima cazzo ti
chiami bravo che è morto occhio
piano piano piano piano piano si cavalca
occhio corri corri adesso che culo
sempre in mamma mia ragazzo che ho
rischiato mettimi col monte dai mettimi
full monty fargli perdere di nuovo tanto
ultimo video sulla playstation giusto
per provarlo jobso da un mamma mia la
movida o l'unica volta che ho vinto
jobso dow è stato sulla playstation
quindi vediamo se le story vincere sordi
station perché sul pc non mi comincio
dal nostro come mai
insomma b station boh la prima volta ha
portato bene
2 cactus c'è andropoli siano l'anno
eliminato le sigaraie flop sono già già
parto che sono caduto perfetto
c'è molta più probabilità che però cade
a ca ta la mia perché sono i must
isolate porca vacca se minimale se mi
cade la mia dovuto farmi i ragazzi sono
già pronto a farlo sono tutti isolate
raga tutti isolate a cascata con la in
fondo ok ok ok ok x fator cav h eccolo
ora devo stare attento che se cascherà
altre è un casino
ok che sia poi la cascatella uno si è
salvato
l'altro no ok
minchia raga siamo i tre buono buono o
siti cities i quali devo darti la terza
e non che cada adesso non so più se
cadono le altre piattaforme
no non si sono poi quando che culo e
vabbè ma l'altro non si sono oppongono
mai che sfiga
ecco ecco è caduto cerasi 2 io non l'ho
fuori merda gli oggetti di twilight
oddio non ci credo no no
ma cos'è successo lega fermi non ho
capito ma cosa ma cosa se non è vero ma
non e vero perche ho perso ma come bene
ragazzi perfetto destro era mi
riguardava il video con voi perché non
ho cup
non ho capito non ho capito e sono
caduto primo ma sono ho vinto io
quindi o quello è caduto pesava di più
perché gli pesava al costume andato più
giù ma che cacchio ne so io spero che vi
sia piaciuto
la playstation mi porta bene a molto
pare volgari giocato sulla presenza
discreta gara lasciate un commento su
sta roba perché non ho capito neanche io
e noi ci vediamo come sempre alle
pressioni della ragazza
[Musica]